the jogan experience but we actually
found all started with an interview that
we did with an assassin in La yeah um
about 15 minutes from my house in LA and
uh we have a contact in La that um
whenever we're looking at and the black
markets we contact him and ask him hey
do you know anyone who's basically
making meth or drugs or guns or whatnot
and you know the off chance that he knew
an assassin we contacted him and he said
he actually did he knew a guy um he
didn't think he was going to talk to us
but maybe he did because he was close to
him and and eventually this guy agreed
to talk to us and we met him in the
corner and as we're driving there so
we're driving there with our local
contact is taking us to meet this guy
and he told us hey be very careful this
guy is like the way he said it is like
he's bipolar kind of like he acts as if
he's bipolar one moment he's happy and
the next he can just freak out and
nobody knows why he's really hard
difficult to deal with and I I asked him
are you sure he's an assassin or is it
possible that he's just boasting that
happen sometimes and he said no no no
I've seen this guy being offered $80,000
to go and kill someone and I know this
is what he does everybody knows this guy
in in his community in his group so he
operates in America he does yeah I asked
him where he's based in LA but he says
it's all over the United States mainly
wow and he yeah he as soon as I met him
he took out his gun and he said you guys
if you if this is a [__] setup you
guys are all it's going to be really
easy to kill you all right now and it
was me and three or four other people
and my fear we told them we're not it's
not a setup so I just came here because
I trust my my buddy but you know you
don't [__] me if the police shows up you
guys are all dead so we're in a corner
of
La close to downtown and I'm constantly
looking at the end of the road thinking
if the police shows up by for any reason
right he's going to think it's us yeah
and this is not good so yeah it it was a
quick interview but chilling one how
many people has this guy
whacked he said he said more than 10 um
he didn't say exactly how many I asked
him um I also asked started asking him
personal questions about do you have a
family because he was saying he doesn't
kill women or children I asked him but
do you have kids and do you realize like
what would it be like for your kids to
live without you like you're doing same
to other kids right he got really mad at
my questions and said don't [__] ask
me emotional question or something like
that personal questions and this
interview is over and left what was his
background he said uh he came from a
really tough family
um and that yeah involved in drugs and
guns and all of it and he I think
realized early on that he could do this
and a lot of other people can't and he
was able to do it and he gets well paid
and he does it how's one even apply to a
job like that yeah and and you I mean
that was my fear when we started looking
into this story because it's a little
bit of a Hollywood myth right like this
isn't really exist and all those stories
that you can go on the dark web and find
an assassin most of that is [__] so
that was my fear but I do trust this
contact and and we actually then ended
up going to South Africa that has one of
the highest assassination rates in the
world and spent time with a bunch of
different um inabi which are as they are
called in South Africa um and that was F
[__] crazy as well so we spent time
with one his name is JoJo young guy and
his story is insane and that that he was
a lot nicer a lot more approachable but
has killed like over 30 people and uh
and gets paid $1,500 per hit and you
know thousands of people have died in
just the past few years at the hands of
assassins in in South Africa wow and a
lot of it is happens in the taxi
industry so there's like 70% I think of
commuters in South Africa commute on
these taxis basically it's like these
Vans and they're worth a lot of money
and it's sort of a cash business and the
owners of these taxi companies are
routinely being killed so we spent time
with a taxi owner who owns one of these
companies and he had a bullet for AK-47
on his head that he showed us it was a
$1 million um prize for anyone who
killed him and this is a crazy guy and
there his Rivals were just across the
street with all their taxis the other
company that he says are trying to kill
him so he's surrounded by bodyguards
with AK-47 at all time AK-47s at all
time and he was like do you want to go
across the street with me and film me as
I get close to the other guys and see
what happens it's like sure so we start
walking towards the rivals and
immediately there's a group of heavily
armed men walking towards us immediately
within like seconds and this happens
every day like people are killed every
day so yeah and then back to the
Assassin and they don't have a hard time
talking to you about this I I would
think that there's no upside to them
discussing this with you but potentially
they could get caught yeah um we go
through a lot of you know to make sure
that we protect their identities but I
think JoJo this assassin is a good
example of why they talk to us so we
spent an hour and a half more or less
two hours talking to him and he tells us
a story of how he became an assassin his
parents were killed when he was young um
he was about 9 years old or something
he felt like he was left with no
protection he started carrying a knife
and his parents were killed by an
assassin by the way as well um and he
and then eventually he got involved in a
drug business and then eventually people
were paying him to go out paying him
much more money to go out and kill and
he says yeah at the beginning I had to
get drugged and drunk to be able to do
it um but now I'm used to it I'm
coldblooded and I'm I'm used to it and
we started talking about the cycle of
violence right because he also said he
doesn't killed women and children and I
asked him but do you realize that you
are traumatized from the experience that
you had that your parents were killed
and now you're doing the same thing to
other kids it's like I actually never
thought of that and then he started
talking about hey really wants to quit
and he's been thinking but he doesn't
have he can't get a job and all of
that